bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
sur l'antenne de de Public Sénat pour
suivre cet après-midi deux discussions
autour de deux textes importants tout
d'abord le projet de loi égalité femmes
homme ce texte qui a été présenté en
Conseil des ministres il y a un an par
la ministre nadjad valobelkassen et bien
arrive au terme de son parcours
législatif ce projet de loi égalité
femmes hommes devrait être adopté
définitivement par le Parlement cet
après-midi et notamment par le Sénat
alors je vous rappelle que ce texte vise
à renforcer la parité notamment dans les
partis politiques mais aussi les
conseils d'administration des
entreprises et également les médias un
projet de loi qui vise aussi à renforcer
la lutte contre les violences conjugales
et puis qui instaure aussi un nouveau
dispositif expérimental sur le paiement
ou le non paiement plutôt des pensions
alimentaires donc je vous propose tout
de suite de rejoindre l'hémicycle pour
suivre bien la discussion la fin la
discussion et l'adoption définitive de
ce texte entre sur l'égalité femmes
hommes et puis après cette discussion et
bien nous suivrons la discussion autour
d'une proposition de loi très attendue
cet après-midi au Sénat sur les taxis et
les VTC une position du Sénat qui est
attendue puisqu'elle permettrait un peu
plus de concilier les positions entre
les taxis et les VTC et leur permettre
de continuer à travailler euh ensemble
ou en tout cas en parallèle donc très
bonne séance à tous sur notre
antenne l'ordre du jour mesdames et
messieurs appelle l'examen des
conclusions de la commission mixte
paritaire chargé d'élaborer un texte sur
les dispositions restant en discussion
du projet de loi pour l'égalité réelle
entre les femmes et les hommes dans la
discussion générale la parole est à
Madame Virginie CLA rapporteur pour le
Sénat de la commission mixte paritaire
chers collègues vous avez la
paroleés madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le sénateur et
président de la commission des lois et
mes chers collègues féminines présentes
ici je pense que vous ne m'en voudrez
pas si je oh pardon je ne vous avais pas
vu vous étiez trop loin sur ma droite
je retire euh je pense que vous ne m'en
voudrez pas si je commence par un un
bref exposé historique je remonterai pas
jusqu'à la près préhistoire mais quand
même jusqu'au milieu du 16e siècle dans
le désordre et sans faire les choses de
façon forcément très très détaillée mais
plutôt en émaillant mon propos
d'anecdotes ou de faits qui me sembleent
particulièrement
important et en tout cas éclairant par
rapport à au texte de loi que nous
examinons aujourd'hui en tout cas au
résultat de de la CMP je vais commencer
par l'ordonnance du 21 avril
1944 on a déjà dû la rappeler des
milliers de fois cette ordonnance qui
donnait le droit de vote aux femmes mais
on oublie souvent que c'était aux femmes
mais aussi aux militaires qui finalement
à l'époque étaient considéré comme les
femmes pour n'avoir pas suffisamment
d'esprits critiqu par eux-mêmes et pour
ne donc pas être plus en plus que les
femmes en droit de voter donc finalement
militaire et femm ont obtenu le même
statut et le même droit de vote en même
temps c'était le 21 avril 1944 et puis
de l'eau a coulé sous les ponts et dans
les années 60 les manuels scolaires
fleurissaient et notamment l'un d'entre
eux que j'ai choisi presque oisard mais
pas tout à fait qui était destiné aux
femmes et qui s'appelait économie
domestique pour les femmes donc celui-là
il été publié en 1960 je vais pas tout
vous lire simplement quelques quelques
extraits parce qu'ils sont quand même
assez intéressants pour voir l'évolution
entre 44 et et 60 euh alors ça
commençait par enfin ça commençait ce
que je vais vous dire commence par
faites en sorte que le souper soit prêt
devinez on s'adressait bien évidemment
aux femmes préparer les choses à
l'avance le soir précédent s'il le faut
afin qu'un délicieux repas à l'attende
monsieur à son retour du travail c'est
une façon de lui faire savoir que vous
avez pensé à lui et que vous vous
souciez de ses besoins la plupart des
hommes ont faim lorsqu'ils rentrent à la
maison et la perspective d'un bon repas
particulièrement son plat favori fait
partie de la nécessaire chaleur d'un
accueil soyez prêt
prenez 15 minutes pour vous reposer afin
d'être détendu lorsqu'il rentre
retouchez votre maquillage mettez un
ruban dans vos cheveux madame la
ministre vous aurez du mal et soyez
fraîche et avenante il a passé la
journée en compagnie de gens surchargés
de soucis et de travail donc soyez en
jouet et un peu plus intéressante que
ces derniers sa dure journée a besoin
d'être égayé et c'est un de vos devoirs
de faire en sorte qu'elle le soit
pendant les mois les plus froids de
l'année il vous faudra préparer et
allumer le feu dans la cheminée auprès
duquel il puisse se détendre votre mari
aura le sentiment d'avoir atteint un
havre de repos et d'ordre et cela vous
rendra également heureuse puisque en
définitive veillez à son confort vous
procurera une immense satisfaction
personnelle réduisez tous les bruits au
minimum au moment de son arrivée
éliminez tout bruit de machine à laver
de séchoir à linge ou d'aspirateur
essayez d'encourager les enfants à être
calme soyez heureuse de le voir
accueillez-le avec un chaleureux sourire
et montrez de la sincérité dans votre
désir de lui plaire écoutez-le il se
peut que vous ayez une douzaine de
choses importantes à lui dire mais son
arrivée à la maison n'est pas le moment
opportun laissez-le parler d'abord
souvenez-vous que ces sujets de
conversation sont plus importants que
les vôtres faites en sorte que la soirée
lui appartienne et surtout ne vous
plaignez jamais s'il rentre tard à la
maison ou s'il sort pour dîner ou pour
aller dans d'autres lieux de
divertissement sans vous au contraire
essayez de faire en sorte là encore que
votre foyer soit un havre de paix
d'ordre et de tranquillité où votre mari
puisse détendre son corps et son esprit
ne l'accueillez pas avec vos plaintes et
vos problèmes ne vous plaignez pas s'il
est en retard à la maison pour le souper
ou même s'il reste dehors toute la nuit
considérez cela comme mineur comparez à
ce qu'il a pu endurer pendant la journée
installez-le confortablement
proposez-lui de se détendre dans une
chaise confortable ou d'aller s'étendre
dans la chambre à coucher préparez- lui
une boisson fraîche ou chaude arranger
l'oreiller proposez-lui d'enlever ses
souliers parle d'une voix douce
apaisante et laante ne lui posez pas de
question sur ce qu'il a fait et ne
remettez jamais en cause son jugement ou
son intégrité souvenez-vous qu'il est le
maître du foyer et qu'en tant que tel il
exercera toujours sa justice avec sa
volonté pardon avec justice et
honnêteté lorsqu'il a fini de souper
débarrassez la table et faites
rapidement la vaisselle si votre mari se
propose de vous aider décliner son offre
car il risquerait de se sentir obligé de
la répéter par la suite et après une
longue journée de la beur il n'a nul
besoin de travail
supplémentaire bien que l'hyiène
féminine soit d'une grande importance
votre mari fatigué ne serait faire la
queue devant la salle de bain comme il
aurait à le faire pour prendre son train
cependant assurez-vous d'être d'être à
votre meilleur avantage en allant vous
coucher essayez d'avoir une apparence
qui soit avenante sans être aguicheuse
si vous devez vous appliquer de la crème
sur le visage ou mettre des bigouis
attendez son sommeil car cela pourrait
le choquer de s'endormir sur un tel
spectacle je vous passe peut-être les
détails sur si votre mari suggère des
relations intimes et cetera et cetera
vous le trouverez sur Internet de toute
façon non vous voulez la
suite bon alors je je vais pas tout vous
lire mais peut-être quand même si votre
mari vous suggère l'accouplement accep
alors avec humilité tout en gardant à
l'esprit que le plaisir d'un homme est
plus important que celui d'une femme
lorsqu'il atteint l'orgasme un petit
gémissement de votre part l'encouragera
et sera tout à fait suffisant pour
indiquer toute forme de plaisir que vous
ayez pu avoir vous pouvez alors remonter
le réveil afin d'être debout peu de
temps avant lui le matin cela vous
permettra de tenir sa tasse de thé du
matin à sa disposition lorsqu'il se
réveillera 1960 c'est quand même pas si
vieux que ça je suis née très peu de
temps après et je pense que qui a eu
quelques manuels scolaires de ce type là
encore pendant les quelques années qui
ont suivi depuis on a c'était sans doute
très bien je je je je je pensais bien
que j'aurais quelques approbations
masculines quand même dans
l'assemblée depuis malgré tout les
choses ont un peu bougé et aujourd'hui
on s'interroge parfois aussi sur le rôle
notamment de la première dame en France
on s'est encore jamais interrogé sur le
rôle d'un éventuel premier monsieur mais
bon on s'interroge sur celui d'une
première dame et j'aimerais quand même
rappeler dans cette enceinte
que on pourrait peut-être réfléchir à ce
qu'il y a vraiment un rôle à tenir pour
une première dame ou un premier monsieur
en France sachant que la loi n'y fait
explicitement mention que pour les
courriers des détenus qui lorsqu'ils
sont adressés à l'épouse du président de
la République ne peuvent pas être
ouverts mais c'est la seule référence
dans notre arsenal de de texte à l'époux
ou l'épouse du président de la
République on est en 2014 et malgré tout
en 2014 moi j'ai encore entendu des
jeunes femmes autour de moi et très
récemment elles se reconnaîtront
certaines d'entre elles me dire
bah ouais quand il a fallu que je
choisisse que je me fasse un plan de
carrière je me suis dit que si je
choisissais telle carrière je Seris
obligé de déménager tous les deux ou 3
ans et je me suis dit que mon mari ne me
suivrait pas donc j'ai choisi une autre
carrière moins intéressante mais j'ai
choisi de ne pas faire bouger mon mari
tous les deux ou 3 ans heureusement
quand même j'ai aussi des exemples
contraires au cours des rencontres ou
des anecdotes qui m'ont été rapportées
ces temps-ci j'ai par exemple rencontré
il y a déjà une vingtaine ou une
trentaine d'années un praticien une
praticien hospitalière qui était marié
avec un moniteur d'auto-école qui a eu
trois enfants et à la stupéfaction
générale de tout son entourage madame la
ministre serait très contente si elle
était là aujourd'hui parce que c'est son
mari qui a choisi de prendre un congé
parental pour garder les enfants je vous
donnerai ces coordonnées si vous voulez
alleer la voir un jour avec le nouveau
texte de loi en l'occurrence je connais
aussi même des administrateurs au sein
du Sénat qui parfois sont chargés de
garder leurs enfants et qui parfois du
coup font des allers-retours entre des
réunions au Sénat la garde des enfants
et se débrouille quand même pour que le
boulot soit fait en temps et en heure
même s'il est fait sur des moments de
congé ou sur des moments plus tardifs
encore dans la dans la nuit donc malgré
tout on
avance l'expression de prince
consort qui existe quand même de plus en
plus vous savez le mari de Madame ou le
conjoint de madame c'est prince consort
qui se rend compte qui parl entre eux
qui généralement en plaisante un petit
peu mais qui aujourd'hui c'est sans
doute un progrès se font appeler aussi
par les services de formation
des madames justement et notamment j'ai
récemment entendu parler d'un monsieur
marié avec une préfette et qui s'est
fait appelé par le service de formation
qui lui proposait gentiment une place
dans la formation dessinée aux épouses
des préfets avec un programme
extrêmement intéressant c'est la seule
chose qui me pourquoi pas bien sûr la
seule chose qui me soutient peu c'est
que il n'avait pas été imaginé une seule
minute que la personne en question
puisse travailler et on lui proposait
d'apprendre à faire des plans de table
on lui proposait d'apprendre à recevoir
on lui proposait d'apprendre le
protocole et cetera et cetera et Cera
mais c'est aujourd'hui un traitement qui
est réservé aussi bien aux époux qu'aux
épouses après tout voyons-y là un
avantage etyons voyons-y là pardon un
pas en avant
encore après tout c'est peut-être
l'égalité supérieure on va parler
aujourd'hui d'égalité réelle ce sera
peut-être l'égalité supérieure de demain
tout ceci pour vous dire que quand je
vous ai dit que je remonterai au milieu
du 16e siècle il y avait quand même
quelqu'un au milieu du 16e siècle qui
était certainement très très en avance
et qui aurait sans doute été heureux
d'être ici aujourd'hui c'était Montaigne
Montaigne qui a quand même écrit les
femmes ont raison de se rebeller contre
les lois parce que nous les avons faites
sans
elle et aujourd'hui heureusement
quelques hommes nous ont rejoint parce
que sinon j'aurais dit ne les faisons
pas non plus c'est loi sans les hommes
ou alors considérons qu'ils ont
tellement confiance en nous qu'on peut
les faire sans eux et qu'on réussira
malgré tout un très beau texte pour
revenir justement à ce texte madame la
ministre et de façon cette fois-ci
beaucoup plus sérieuse et aux
conclusions de de la CMP qui je vous
vous rassure a abouti à un texte que je
vous propose que je vais vous proposer
au vote tout à l'heure un certain nombre
il resta une trentaine d'articles plus
l'intitulé du texte de loi en discussion
sur cette sur cette CMP sur un certain
nombre d'articles je ne vais pas tous
vous redétailler les différences entre
la l'écriture Assemblée nationale et
l'écriture Sénat était essentiellement
de forme des questions de dates ou des
références juridiques qu'il fallait
modifier ça a été fait et très bien fait
par nos collègues de l'Assemblée le
Sénat aussi a révisé encore les quelques
dernières petites chos
jusqu'au dernier moment et il restait à
la fin 18 points seulement sur lesquels
il y avait une discussion de fond à
avoir et sur lesquels nous avons trouvé
des accords alors je vais pas prendre
les choses dans l'ordre du texte je vais
plutôt prendre les choses dans l'ordre
des accords donc le texte de l'Assemblée
nationale a été adopté par la commission
mixte paritaire sur l'article de bisb
c'est-à-dire l'opportunité de donner des
autorisations d'absence de de permettre
au futurs PIR de bénéficier
d'autorisation d'absence pour se rendre
aux examens prénataux de leur compagnes
dans la limite de 3 euh donc sur ce
point-là nous sommes tombés d'accord euh
sans forcément être archi convaincu euh
que cette mesure permettra au pères de
s'investir très en amont en tout cas à
certains d'entre eux de s'investir très
en amont euh dans laavenue d'un enfant à
la maison mais en tout cas ça permettra
à certains d'entre eux de le faire plus
facilement donc c'est une bonne mesure
et le Sénat s'est donc rallé à la
position de l'Assemblée sur le sujet sur
l'article 2 B et sur la la BPI avec un
objectif d'encouragement à
l'entrepreneuriat féminin nous étions
d'accord sur le fond c'est simplement la
rédaction qui a vu des
modifications proposées par le Sénat via
une
simplification des mesures qui étaient
proposées
euh un article qui avait été beaucoup
discuté en commission des lois qui
consistait en la le remplacement de la
notion de bon père de famille dans T nos
textes de loi par le terme de
raisonnable le Sénat avait choisi
d'autres termes plus et diligeent si je
me rappelle bien qui avait été proposé
par notre collègue Esther Benbassa et
finalement le Sénat s'est rallié au
terme de raisonnable ou raisonnablement
qui avait déjà des antécédents entre
guillemets juridiques si je peux
m'exprimer ainsi et qui nous a paru
après tout suffisamment parlant pour se
rallier là encore à la à l'option de
l'Assemblée
nationale sur le versement de la pension
alimentaire alors ça les nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale il tenait
beaucoup tenait beaucoup à ce que la
notion de virement bancaire apparaisse
dans le texte de loi en nous disant
qu'il existait de nombreux cas dans
lesquels après une séparation monsieur
se montrait récal Citran pour verser
régulièrement la pension alimentaire et
prenait un malin plaisir à faire en
sorte que son ex épouse ou son excagne
doiv la lui réclamer plusieurs fois
avant de l'obtenir tous les mois et le
virement bancaire qui était déjà de fait
autorisé sans être explicitement cité
dans la loi aujourd'hui mais était déjà
de faites autorisé n'était semble-t-il
pas suffisamment utilisé ou pas
suffisamment connu par les juges qui
ordonnent les conventions et les
règlements de pension alimentaires euh
donc sur l'insistance de nos collègues
de l'Assemblée nationale nous avons donc
introduit le terme de virement bancaire
de façon très explicite dans la loi pour
permettre le versement des pensions
alimentaires mais nous avons rajouté
nous avons tenu au scénar rajouté
d'ailleurs ou tout autre mode de
paiement dans la mesure où tout le monde
ne dispose pas d'un compte bancaire
quand les séparations ont lieu les
comptes bancaires sont pas forcément
toujours 10 soins euh il peut y avoir
des personnes en interdit bancaire pour
lesquels le le virement bancaire est une
impossibilité aussi de règlement euh
voilà donc je pense que l'objectif de
nos collègue de l'Assemblée nationale
est atteint on pensera peut-être plus
souvent au virement bancaire mais pour
autant tous les autres modes de paiement
de la pension alimentaire sont à la
disposition du Juge pour être positionné
dans les conventions euh accord aussi
sur la version de l'Assemblée nationale
pour les procédures de de récusation
pardon en matière de procédure
disciplinair universitaire là il y avait
pas de de souci majeur sur le sujet euh
sur l'article 17 qui était un un
amendement porté par madame taska et qui
concernait la diffusion d'images de
violence aux personnes sur Internet euh
là encore nous nous sommes rendus aux
arguments de nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale tout en voulant
attirer aujourd'hui l'attention du
gouvernement par votre intermédiaire
madame la ministre sur ce sujet-là qui
est un sujet important madame taska
visait dans son amendement les images
violentes euh prises par les adolescents
de plus en plus malheureusement euh qui
sortent leur portable et qui sont
d'ailleurs incités aujourd'hui à sortir
leur port able au moindre événement un
peu inhabituel qui se déroule autour
d'eux et à filmer la scène et puis à la
mettre sur internet
indépendamment de ce genre de scène qui
se fait volontairement dans le cadre de
harcèlement et cetera c'est un
comportement qui n'est pas excusable
c'est un comportement qu'on ne peut pas
encourager et l'objectif de madame taska
était d'affirmer très clairement par le
retrait et le blocage de ces sites des
site qui portait ces images là le
blocage par les fournisseurs d'accès
Internet indiqué de façon très très
claire notamment au aux jeunes
coutumiers de ce genre de pratique que
c'était une pratique interdite
dangereuse et cetera et cetera nos
collègues de l'Assemblée à juste titre
nous ont fait remarquer que les
fournisseurs d'accès Internet n'ont pas
les moyens juridiques de vérifier la
réalité des images en question et que
une scène de violence peut-être feinte
simulée peut-être une comédie peut-être
une farce certes de mauvais goût mais
une farce quand même faite par des
jeunes et que le le blocage des sites
qui fournissaient ces images entraîaiit
la responsabilité pénale des fournisseur
d'accès internet donc pour ces raisons
nous nous sommes rendus aux arguments de
nos collègues de l'Assemblée
effectivement nous sommes donc revenus à
leur écriture en supprimant cette
disposition mais il semble qu'il y a
quand même là madame la ministre
vraiment alors peut-être dans le cadre
du projet de loi terrorisme qui va
arriver et qui traite je le sais de ces
sujets puisque l'Assemblée nationale
elle même a traité il a mis des
amendements je crois sur ce sur ce type
de sujet hier ou très récemment il y a
vraiment une articulation à voir entre
la responsabilité des fournisseurs
d'accès Internet net et les moyens qu'on
leur donne d'exercer leur responsabilité
c'est-à-dire de vérifier l'origine des
images alors est-ce que c'est à eux de
le faire ou est-ce que c'est à une
autorité judiciaire je ne sais pas j'ai
pas la réponse aujourd'hui mais a il y a
clairement une articulation à trouver
entre les émissions de ces images leur
vérification et l'interdiction
éventuelle d'accès ou le blocage des
sites par les fournisseurs d'accès
Internet il y a là un véritable enjeu
d'éducation nous semble-t-il même si
nous avons effectivement nous nous
sommes rendus une fois de plus aux
arguments de nos collègues de
l'Assemblée pour être d'accord sur le
fait que c'était sans doute pas le bon
texte et pas le le bon
moment l'utilisation du nom de famille
dans les relations des usagers avec
l'administration alors aujourd'hui ça
existe déjà je vais pas vous remonter
encore l'histoire mais aujourd'hui c'est
déjà le cas il n'empêche que c'est pas
connu mal connu méconnu voir parfois
foulé du pied encore une anecdote
quelqu'un d'autre qui m'a raconté que à
l'occasion d'un renouvellement de
chquier le nom de son épouse avait dit
disparu et déchqué pour qu' ne portait
plus que son nom à lui euh donc
clairement cette disposition est
méconnue donc après tout de la réécrire
clairement dans la loi qui sort
aujourd'hui n'est pas une mauvaise chose
même si initialement nous n'y étions pas
forcément très favorable je reconnais
que moi-même je reçois encore des
papiers de la sécurité sociale au nom de
mon ex-mari alors que j'ai même jamais
utilisé ce nom-là dans la vie courante
donc clairement il faut peut-être
réaffirmer effectivement les choses euh
sur l'objectif de parité aux membres de
la institut de chacune des académies le
Sénat s'est rallié là aussi à la
position de l'Assemblée euh l'assemblée
s'est rallié à la position du Sénat sur
un certain nombre d'autres points et
notamment sur l'article 18 bis qui
posait un objectif de parité à la tête
des exécutifs locaux autrement dit le
maire était un homme le premier adjoint
éit une femme et vice-versa et cetera
donc là très clairement pour nous il y
avait un souci de constitutionnalité
puisque ce sont deux élections qui a
priori ne doivent pas être liées donc
égalité de candidature totale sur ces
deux élections et à partir partir du
moment où le sexe de la première
personne enfin le le le le sexe du
premier agjon du premier vice-président
était dépendant du résultat de la
première élection on ne respectait plus
ce principe d'égalité des candidatures
donc la mort dans l'âme certes mais nos
collègues de l'Assemblée nationale se
sont là aussi ralliés à notre position
euh toujours en matière d'élection la
date d'entrée en vigueur des
dispositions qui clarifi les règles de
remplacement des conseiller
communautaire on comprenait pas bien
pourquoi il fallait attendre le 1er
janvier 2015 alors que c'est une mesure
qui est très attendue sur le terrain
simplifier un petit peu les choses et
permettre que parfois une femme puisse
remplacer un homme dans les conseillers
communautaires dé missionnaires ce qui
aujourd'hui dans le texte tel qu'il est
tel qu'il est ISU de nos travaux n'est
pas possible donc là-dessus l'Assemblée
nationale c'est aussi rallé à nos
arguments l'instauration de la parité
dans les conseils d'administration de
tous les établissements publics locaux
même si sur le fond et sur le principe
on a envie de dire oui bien sûr il faut
mais dans la réalité et et dans la
pratique et dans le concret c'est
malheureusement au jour d'aujourd'hui un
impossible parce que les les conseils
d'administration des établissements
publics locaux c'est les cases des
écoles c'est les CCAS c'est les conseils
d'administration des collèges et des
lycées et instaurer une parité entre
guillemets de forces d'abord c'est pas
forcément possible dans les toutes
petites communes je parle là des
conseils d'écooles ou des CCAS pour
lesquels la parité n'est elle-même pas
présente dans les conseils municipaux et
puis ensuite ce sont des nominations euh
par des des des des instances
nominatives différentes donc là il n'y a
malheureusement pas possibilité au jour
d'aujourd'hui d'avancer d'une façon
brutale sur ce sujet sur l'article 21 où
euh nos collègues de l'Assemblée
souhaaiiter un principe de nullité des
nominations aux emplois d'encadrement de
la fonction publique qui serait
intervenu en violation de l'obligation
de parité là encore même si on avait
envie de dire oui sur le principe ça
posait des d'énormes problèmes
constitutionnels peut-être l'assemblée
n'a pas voulu entendre ses argument là
mais en tout état de cause des problèmes
concrets et pratiques euh de de de
décision en domino euh peut-être de
retour de certaines personnes pour des
raisons qui ne les concernent absolument
pas des traitements inférieurs à ceux
qu'ils avaient par le le dispositif même
tel qu'il était proposé à savoir la
parité à tout moment une vérification
une fois par an et donc des nullités de
nominations qui qui seraient arrivé
intervenu une fois par an seulement donc
ça posait un tel problème aussi une fois
plus pratique et concret euh que là
encore nos collègues de l'Assemblée ont
accepté de nous suivre il n'y a que pour
euh les les les circonstances où ça ne
pose pas de souci que cette obligation
aujourd'hui euh est
imposé sur le dernier article qui est
très l'article 23 pardon pas le dernier
sur l'article 23 qui est très technique
et qui autorise le gouvernement à
légiférer par ordonnance pour instaurer
la parité euh dans un certain nombre
d'instances euh là encore nous sommes
nous avons trouvé un compromis et un
accord avec l'Assemblée nationale à
savoir le gouvernement légiférera par
ordonnance pour les autorités
administratives indépendantes et les
autorités publiques indépendantes donc
autorité par autorité et par contre pour
l'ensemble des instant sens consultatif
collégial une disposition balai est
maintenue et va donc permettre là aussi
d'avancer sur le
sujet oui je me dépêche madame la
Présidente j'en ai presque terminé j'en
ai presque terminé j'ai plus que trois
points à voir sur l'article 7 et
l'ordonnance de protection un désaccord
subsistait aussi sur la possibilité pour
les femmes victimes de violence et
protégé par une ordonnance de protection
dissimuler leur domicile c'est possible
aujourd'hui euh la demande qui était
faite était de les autoriser se
domicilier chez une personne morale
qualifiée autrement dit dans une
association nous avons au Sénat des
réticences sur le sujet nous pensons que
ça risque de les mettre encore plus en
anger parce que de les remettre en
évidence mais d'autres et nos collègues
notamment de l'Assemblée nationale
estimaient que c'était une solution qui
allait permettre d'avancer sur le sujet
c'est une possibilité c'est pas une
obligation donc c'est cette disposition
qui a été retenue ainsi que l'obligation
de parité dans les conseils
d'administration ou de surveillance des
sociétés anonymes non côté euh en les
avançant à 2017 au lieu de 2000 côté
pardon 2017 au lieu de 2020 et pour les
non côtés en étendant cette obligation
pour les entreprises de 250 à 499
salariés il reste le titre j'ai souris
tout à l'heure dessus en parlant
d'égalité supérieure à la place
d'égalité réelle nos collègues de
l'Assemblée tenaient au terme de réel
dans le titre une égalité réelle en
disant cette fois-ci c'est vrai ça va
avancer ça va
bouger nous au Sénat on tenait plutôt à
l'égalité comme notre devise Liberté
égalité fraternité mais làdessus
monsieur le Président sur ce fera sans
doute un plaisir tout à l'heure de vous
de vous donner un argumentaire beaucoup
plus détaillé que le mien en tout état
cause avec ou sans homes c'est une très
belle loi merci madame la ministre et je
vous engage à la voter dans sa version
sortie de la CMP merci Madame la
rapporteur la parole est à Madame na
najade valobelcassem excusez-moi madame
la ministre ministre des Droits des
Femmes de la ville de la Jeunesse et des
Sports
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
madame la rapporteur madame la
présidente de la délégation droits des
femmes nous sommes en train d'arriver au
au bout d'un travail qui est
véritablement à l'honneur du Parlement
et je le dis en pesant chaque mot avec
beaucoup de simplicité beaucoup
d'humilité et en même temps de
reconnaissance parce que vous avez été
les avant-gardes les têtes de pont les
premières lignes du combat pour les
droits des femmes j'en étis témoin ici
même lorsque au mois de Juin Juillet
2012 déjà nous discuions nous discutions
du texte contre le harcèlement sexuel ce
projet de loi cadre c'est une première
et j'espère que c'est un commencement
nous l'avons préparé ensemble avec un
regard neuf avec une approche totalement
intégrée des politiques d'égalité et une
philosophie de de l'action qui je crois
répond bien au défis de notre temps ces
défis ce sont ceux de loi qui
s'appliquent ce sont ceux de lois sur
l'égalité qui sont respectés mais c'est
aussi le défi du changement des
mentalités d'un partage nouveau des
responsabilités parentales d'une
exigence de parité qui soit enfin
pleinement effective je vous avez
demandé au commencement de cet examen
d'affirmer avec moi et vous l'avez fait
l'ambition de réaliser égalité réelle
c'est une ambition qui est très attendue
par nos concitoyennes en particulier et
c'est vrai que votre commission mixte
paritaire a finalement choisi de retenir
ce titre pour ce projet de loi il prend
tout son sens ce projet de loi c'est
l'affaire de tous parce que nous y avons
contribué tous ensemble mais au-delà
parce que Parlement gouvernement
collectivité locale entreprise citoyens
nous en serons tous les garants et tous
les acteurs chacun dans nos
responsabilités le Parlement et chacun
des groupes de vos assemblées ont
apporté à ce projet de loi une
contribution extrêmement
précieuse dans l'esprit d'ailleurs d'une
coconstruction législative qui est
plutôt de tradition sur les textes
relatif aux droits des femmes et que
j'espère vous allez concrétiser à
nouveau tout à l'heure lors de vos votes
je veux à cet instant saluer l'excellent
travail de la rapporteur Virginie
Cless je veux saluer a les contributions
des rapporteurs des commissions saisies
pour avis Michel meunier marieevon
Blondin je veux vous dire à toutes les
trois que c'est sous votre impulsion et
j'en ai pleinement pris conscience que
ce texte a tellement progressé a pu
aborder des questions nouvelles et que
votre travail de fond a apporté beaucoup
de sérénité à nos débats je le disais
l'égalité c'est l'affaire de tous et
bien sûr tous les ministères sont
concernés par ce texte qui en réalité
matérialise cette cette approche
interministérielle dont j'ai voulu faire
un automatisme depuis que j'ai pris mes
responsabilités en 2012 approche
interministérielle parce que je crois
que c'est la condition de la réussite
d'un changement qui investit toutes les
politiques publiques et tous les
secteurs de la
société avec ce projet de loi c'est une
conception nouvelle que nous affirmons
la politique de l'égalité c'est un
ensemble cohérent qui doit combattre en
même temps et dans un même mouvement
toutes les inégalités d' qu'elles
viennent quel que soit leur mode
d'expression les violences la précarité
des familles monoparentales la
persistance des inégalités entre les
femmes et les hommes dans le milieu
professionnel comme dans la sphère
personnelle ce texte forme Infiné une
belle loi tout au long de nos débats
nous avons veillé à ce que ça reste une
belle loi et j'en suis heureuse nous y
sommes arrivés nous avons été attentif à
ne pas la surcharger de dispositions
bavardes nous l'avons concentré sur
l'essentiel sur ceux qui qui crée de la
norme et qui donnera des outils
véritablement nouveaux pour gagner en
efficacité et en
effectivité cette loi vous l'avez faite
avec nous pour qu'elle soit un puissant
coup d'accélérateur au mouvement pour
l'égalité vous l'avez faite aussi pour
changer très concrètement la vie de nos
concitoyennes et de nos concitoyens dans
tous les domaines et je serai totalement
investi pour que cette loi soit
rapidement appliquée nous publierons je
m'y engage l'ensemble des textes
d'application de la loi avant la fin du
mois de
novembre avec la réforme du congé
parental nous mettons grâce à ce texte
en place une logique nouvelle des
prestations sociales qui doivent
désormais être conçu dès le départ avec
le réflexe de l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes avec la réforme de la
négociation en matière d'égalité
professionnelle avec l'introduction de
cette mesure essentielle d'interdiction
d'accès à la commande publique pour les
entreprises qui ne jouent pas le jeu de
l'égalité professionnelle nous allons on
donner encore plus d'ampleur au
changement que nous avons introduit
depuis 2 ans en la matière tout le monde
le sait désormais il n'y a plus
d'impunité pour ceux qui ne respectent
pas leurs obligations en matière
d'égalité professionnelle c'est un
changement de fond qui se joue là sur
lequel les collectivités publiques sont
désormais responsabilisées et que nous
allons poursuivre avec trois objectifs
faire respecter la normes votées par le
Parlement dialoguer avec les partenaires
sociaux pour aller encore plus loin et
accompagner les entreprises comme nous
l'avons fait en particulier dans ces
neuf régions d'excellence que nous
avions identifié il y a 2 ans dans
lesquels nous avons mené un gros travail
dans lesquels près de 8000 entreprises
ont été formées pour l'essentiel des PME
avec des partenaires sociaux qui sont
désormais au rendez-vous pour faire en
sorte qu'il y ait davantage d'accords
signés sur l'égalité professionnelle
nous amplifieront bien entendu cet
accompagnement toutes les enquêtes le
mone et vous en avez tous témoigné parce
que vous le constatez sur vos
territoires les familles monoparentales
sont trop souvent dans une situation de
grande précarité et c'est vrai en
particulier dans les territoires de la
politique de la ville où j'ai décidé
d'ailleurs de faire de cette lutte
contre la précarité des familles
monoparentales une priorité des
prochains contrats de ville que nous
nous apprêtons à négocier avec les
collectivités et bien grâce à ce projet
de loi si vous l'adoptez en engageant la
mise en œuvre de la garantie publique
contre les payer de pension alimentaire
nous nous attaquons à une cause bien
identifiée de la précarité des mers
isolés en particulier nous apportons
plus de sécurité à ces femmes à leurs
enfants nous mettrons en place cette
garantie publique contre les impayés de
pension alimentaire d'abord dans 20
départements pour la préfigurer avant de
la généraliser en 2016 je peux vous
confirmer pour être allé les voir sur le
terrain l'engagement très fort des CAF
des caisses de de MSA pardon que que je
salue et qui ont bien compris l'intérêt
général qu'il y avait à déployer un
système comme celui-là pour mettre fin à
cette
précarité le travail de coproduction
législative c'est sans doute dans le
domaine des violences que nous l'avons
poussé le plus loin avec des
améliorations sensibles opérées au cours
de la navette et consacrées par la CMP
vous venez de le rappeler madame la
rapporteur une protection renforcée des
femmes dans le cadre de l'ordonnance de
protection une protection renforcée des
femmes étrangères victimes de violence
la définition d'un arsenal législatif de
lutte contre les violences sexuelles
dans l'armée à l'université la lutte
contre le harcèlement moral hors du
cadre du travail l'élargissement du
périmètre du téléphone portable grand
danger aux victimes de viol au-delà des
victimes de violence conjugale la lutte
contre les mariages forcés tout cela est
dans ce texte le résultat c'est une loi
qui va vraiment changer la donne qui
apportera plus de prot tion aux femmes
victimes de violence mais aussi qui
ouvrira des possibilités nouvelles de
prise en charge des auteurs pour mieux
lutter contre la
récidive enfin la parité les évolutions
prévues par le texte seront profonde et
durable n'en doutez pas un instant nous
concrétisons enfin le principe inscrit
dans la constitution de l'égal accès des
femmes et des hommes aux responsabilités
politiques professionnelles et sociales
toutes les ins de la vie sociale seront
désormais concerné et les pouvoirs
publics eux mêmes seront exemplaires
pour lutter contre le plafond de verre
dans la fonction publique nous avons
décidé d'avancer d'un an à 2017 donc
l'obligation d'atteindre 40 % au minimum
de nomination féminine dans les postes
de cadre dirigeant de la fonction
publique les instances consultatives les
établissements publics administratifs
industriels et commerciaux les autorités
administratives indépendantes toutes ces
instances seront concernés par cette
obligation de féminiser leur personnel
ce qui devrait changer la représentation
des femmes dans l'espace public en
attendant qu'en 2017 les nouvelles
règles que vous avez adopté dans cette
loi changent le visage aussi de la
représentation nationale j'ai compris
d'ailleurs que les principaux partis y
étaient prêts par adhésion ou parfois
par souci d'économie nous verrons mais
ce sera sans nul doute un rendez-vous
important mesdames Mames et messieurs
les sénateurs le vote que je sollicite
auprès de vous c'est un vote d'adhésion
pour un texte qui se donne les moyens de
son ambition c'est un vote de conviction
de conviction dans la capacité de notre
pays à faire le dernier saut pour offrir
enfin aux françaises et aux Français la
perspective de vivre dans une société de
l'égalité réelle je vous
remerci merci madame la
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Esther
Benbassa pour le groupe
écologiste madame la présidente madame
la ministre mesdames les rapporteurs mes
chers collègues si les États doivent
être naturellement en première ligne
pour améliorer leur législation dans le
domaine de l'égalité femme homme et je
vous sigrai madame la ministre d'y avoir
contribué par ce projet de loi pour
notre pays c'est bien l'ensemble de la
société qui doit se saisir de ces
questions au-delà c'est encore à chacun
et à chacune d'entre nous à son échelle
de contribuer à remettre en cause les
stéréotypes de genre on me pardonnera ce
mot et les pratiques qui pérénisent les
discriminations dont les femmes sont
traditionnellement victime qu'on me
permett de revenir sur une question qui
pour diverses raisons me tient
particulièrement à cœur celle des
programmes scolaires maintenant que les
ABCD de l'égalité ont quitté l'école
sans avoir eu le temps d'y faire leur
chemin l'élaboration de ces programmes
et l'attention qu'il convient d'y
apporter sont plus que jamais
primordiales ce sont ces programmes qui
fabriquent un savoir qui pour le moment
demeure dominé par le masculin prenons
l'exemple de l'enseignement de
l'histoire traditionnel pilier
idéologique et identitaire d'une nation
l'histoire produit de la mémoire
nationale et façonne la conscience du
citoyen en herbe appelé à contribuer à
la cohésion nationale or nous le savons
l'histoire enseignée dans les écollees
primaires les collèges et les lycées a
trop longtemps été reste encore là
largement une histoire des événements de
la succession des règnes et des
régimes des conquêtes des guerres et des
batailles dans cette histoire làà la
femme est le plus souvent invisible
l'émanuel du primaire faisait bien place
traditionnellement à Jeanne d'c Jeanne
n'est pourtant grande que parce que
puelle elle s'efface devant sa mission
le service du roi et de la patrie elle
n'a aucun pouvoir par elle-même et en
outre elle finit bien sûr en victime à
côté de Jeanne d'autres héroïne féminine
populaire peutvent bien apparaître telle
Blandine dévorée par les lions encore
une héroïne victime viennent ensuite les
régentes en général mauvaises elles sont
femmes ou mèr de roi donc ellees
n'existe pas par elle-même peu de femmes
créatricesces dans ce douteux Panthéon
madame de sévignier rarement là madame
de Lafayette la peintre madame vigé
Lebrun ou Camille Claudel ne sont jamais
évoqué Olympe de gouge jusqu'à récemment
n'était évoqué que dans un unique
manuel dans l'enseignement secondaire
nous avons Marie- anoinette veine et
frivole figure emblématique d'une
représentation déprécié des femmes ou
alors Charlotte Cordet la violente type
de la
des femmes dans la révolution
industrielle des femmes ouvrières on ne
parle guerre à croire que la révolution
industrielle fut un acte purement virile
or il suffit de lire Germinal de Zola
pour voir comment les femmes elles aussi
descendaient dans les mines si les
manuel récent accordent un peu plus de
place aux femmes le bilan reste
toutefois mitigé or l'manuel reflètent
des program qui eux sont fixés au plan
national madame la ministre le rapport
quelle place pour les femmes dans
l'histoire enseignée suggère des remèdes
pour paliier cette absence énoncé en
2004 ils ne sont pas encore pris au
sérieux comme il le devrait quant à
l'enseignement de la géographie aussi
bien dans les programmes que dans les
manuels scolaires la présence féminine y
est bien discrète cette discipline qui
devrait aider à la connaissance du monde
ne fait pas de distinction entre femme
et homme utilisant le terme générique
d'homme sur cinq manuels pris comme
échantillon quatre présent des femmes
sur leur couverture il s'agit
essentiellement des femmes au travail
dans les milieux ruraux des pays du sud
elles s'y adonne au travail de la terre
ou dans les risières aux soins des bêtes
et bien sûr à la préparation de repas à
la garde des enfants ce sont des femmes
exotiques de pays lointains et lorsque
l'on met en avant des femmes moderne
occidental elles sont représentées dans
ces manuels dans des moments de détente
et Associés sauf exception au passé au
bien-être et aux vacances à y regarder
de près on se demande si toutes ces
femmes occidentales ne sont pas
entretenu pour avoir un tel mode de vie
l'image donnée est nettement partielle
et partiale alors même que les
programmes de géographie sont censés
répondre à des objectifs politiques au
sens noble de ce mot lié à la
construction même du projet
républicain on pourrait évidemment
étendre cette enquête à l'enseignement
d'autres disciplines mais je vous
épargnerai parce que c'est encore pire
il reste donc encore beaucoup à faire ce
projet de loi est un précieux jalon pas
une fin en soi ni un aboutissement c'est
donc en ayant clairement conscience que
le débat doit continuer que le groupe
écolog le vote merci merci madame la
sénatrice dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Monsieur André
rechart pour le groupe
UMP
madame la présidente madame la ministre
madame le rapporteur mes chers
collègues permettez-moi d'abord de me
féliciter d'être le seul orateur homme à
intervenir à la tribune dans ce débat
pourtant consacré à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes cela fait peu cela
fait
peu mais à défaut de la quantité
permettez-moi simplement de dire que
peut-être que vous aurez la
qualité mais ce simple constat illustre
s'il fallait à souhait que l'égalité ou
l'inégalité entre les femmes et les
hommes à de multiples facettes ça fait
d'ailleurs de nombreuses années que les
gouvernements de droite et de gauche
tente d'y apporter des réponses plus ou
moins adapté aux situations réelles de
nos concitoyens dans des configurations
économiques et de dépenses publiqu
varié la majorité précédente a permis à
différentes avancées
du droit des femmes c'est pourtant en
matière salariale que l'inégalité reste
la plus flagrante pour un travail égal
le salaire des femmes est encore de 28 %
inférieur à celui des hommes cela
restreint si il faut leur rappeler
largement leur autonomie et leur
indépendance 80 % des salariés à temps
partiel sont des femmes c'est aussi un
frein à leur carrière quant à la
représentation de ces femmes au sein des
structures politiques il suffit de
regarder certaines assemblées et je n'en
cite aucune pour comprendre l'ampleur de
l'inégalité le groupe sauf peut-être
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le groupe UMP
n'aurait pu être que favorable à un
texte dont l'ambition affichée est de
faire évoluer la situation nous avons
d'ailleurs contribué à réduire les
écarts existants à de nombreuses
reprises il en va ainsi de la loi
Hameline relative aux rémunération des
femmes fixées lors des négociations par
branche en est ainsi de la loi sauvadé
permettant un meilleur accès au poes à
responsabilité dans la fonction publique
en passant par la loi visant à lutter
contre les violences faites aux femmes
ou la loi relative à la représentation
équilibrée dans des conseils dans les
conseils
d'administration sur l'égalité
professionnelle
d'abord ce texte comporte un début de
réponses intéressantes qu'il s'agisse de
l'articulation des différentes
négociations sur l'égalité et les
salaires de de l'accompagnement des
retours de congé parental du
renforcement des droits familiaux des
professions libérales de la possibilité
d'utiliser une partie des droits du
compte épargne temps pour financer les
frais de garde d'enfants contre la
précarité aussi le texte apporte des
éléments intéressants ainsi
l'expérimentation du versement entier
payant de la prestation d'accueil du
jeune enfant aux assistants maternels va
faciliter l'accès aux différents modes
de garde pour les famille modestes
contre les violences faites aux femmes
la confirmation et le renforcement du
dispositif de de l'ordonnance de de
protection pardon des femmes victimes de
violence sont à nos yeux essentiels mais
d'autres au points de votre texte madame
la
ministre ne peuvent souscrire notre
assentiment au premier rang desquels la
réforme du congé parental rebaptisé
prestation partagé d'éducation de
l'enfant qui n'est pas opportune selon
ces modalités à nos yeux ce n'est pas un
scoop l'idée d'un meilleur partage de
cette pri pe entre les deux parents va
dans le bon sens mais nous ne croyons
pas que ce soit en nous imissant dans la
vie privée de nos concitoyens et dans
leurs rapports familiaux que nous
apporterons une amélioration à la
conciliation entre vie professionnelle
et familiale votre projet madame la
ministre risque
Infiné d'accentuer les inégalités
familiales entre les femmes et les
hommes sur ce point revenons plutôt sur
les causes poussant les femmes à prendre
le congé dans une plus large proportion
que les hommes les familles en fait
n'ont trop souvent pas le choix
notamment pour deux raisons bien entendu
pour des raisons économiques d'abord le
salaire des femmes étant le plus faible
les familles ne peuvent donc se priver
de la plus haute rémunération de plus le
coout des places de crèche ou auprès des
assistantes maternelles est quasi
inabordable pour certaines familles mais
également pour des raisons
d'organisation ces familles n'ont pas
souvent le choix les places au sein des
structures d'accueil de la petite
enfance manque vous le savez bien car
les collectivités territoriales ne
peuvent tout simplement plus assumer la
charge
de besoins de plus en plus
importants puis comme nous l'avons
répété lors des deux lectures votre
projet contient aussi certaines mesures
contreproductive à nos yeux il risque
notamment même et ce serait un comble de
nuire à l'emploi en rajoutant une
condition supplémentaire à la
candidature à une commande publique nous
vous l'avons déjà dit en première
lecture je vous rappelle qu'en 2012
103000 entreprises étaient concernées
par les marchés publics pour un montant
de plus de 75 milliards d'euros ne
croyez-vous pas madame la ministre que
ce faisant nous risquons de fragiliser
la sphère économique et d'aboutir à une
situation dans laquelle les entreprises
n'auront simplement plus les moyens
d'embaucher que ce ce soit des hommes ou
des femmes d'autant que certaines
entreprises ne peuvent pas et c'est une
évidence appliquer une stricte parité et
certainement pas dans des délais
rapides en définitive madame la
ministre je pense que bien que pétri de
bonnes
intentions loin de la loi cadre
attendu ce texte est un assemblage je
dirais presque l'un de plus assemblage
de dispositions diverses qui modifient
pas moins de H codes et qui à nos yeux
ne s'attaquent pas suffisamment aux
vrais problèmes
culturels qui sont au vrais pardon
obstacles culturels à la mise en œuvre
de de l'égalité entre les femmes et les
hommes il ne prend notamment pas
suffisamment en compte les demandes des
associations de parents ou de
professionnels j'ai donc peur que ce
projet ne soit un iè texte législatif
sur lequel il nous faudra une nouvelle
fois revenir dans un certain temps le
pire serait en raison d'effet négatifs
sur l'économie ou sur les finances
publiques ou peut-être même sur
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
avant de
conclure je souhaiterais en outre
revenir sur un point qui nous choque
profondément celui de la suppression de
la notion de détresse dans le recours à
l'IG
la loi que vous allez voter aujourd'hui
ouvre désormais l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse non plus
seulement aux femmes enceintes que leur
état place en situation de détresse mais
à toute femme qui ne veut pas poursuivre
une grossesse le législateur renonce
ainsi à formuler les raisons pour
lesquelles l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse peut-être pratiquée il il
élargit les possibilités d'accès à
l'avortement à d'autres motifs que la
détresse de la femme sans d'ailleurs les
énoncer
toutes les motivations quelles qu'elles
soi se voi donc conférer une égale
valeur
légale cette rédaction à nos yeux
soulève de graves objections alors
que alors même que sa portée concrète
n'est probablement pas majeur
puisqueaucune instance n'a aujourd'hui
le pouvoir de vérifier la réalité de la
condition de détresse telle qu'elle est
posée par la loi du 17 janvier
19715 relative à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse cette loi dite
loi va CEP
les principes fondamentaux sur lesquels
repose cette loi va sont bien remis en
cause ces principes fondamentaux que
sont notamment le principe du respect de
tout être humain dès le commencement de
sa vie justifie que l'avortement demeure
aujourd'hui légalement interdit hors les
cas prévus par la loi vaille ainsi en
l'absence en vertu pardon de la loi
pénale lorsqu'un avortement est pratiqué
autrement qu'en cas de nécessité et
autrement que dans les conditions
définies par la loi il peut toujours
être
sanctionné la nécessité qui autorise
l'atteinte au principe se traduit depuis
bientôt 40 ans par une exigence légale
l'invocation de sa détresse par la femme
qui demande l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse nous considérons donc au sein
du groupe UMP que le principe du respect
de tout être humain dès le commencement
de sa vie n'est pas respecté c'est
pourquoi je vous annonce déjà que nous
saisirons le Conseil constitutionnel sur
ce point le moment venu je vous remercie
merci monsieur le
sénateur dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame mugeddi
pour le groupe udi
UC madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues madame la
ministre nous avons travaillé ensemble
lors de votre première séance au Sénat
le 11 juillet 2012 sur le projet de loi
relatif au harcèlement sexuel et je suis
heureuse que vous soyez la dernière
interlocutrice de mon mandat de
sénatrice pour en venir à ce projet de
loi pour l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes vous le savez j'ai voté pour
ce texte lors des deux lectures dans
notre hémicycle je ne reviendrai pas sur
toutes les dispositions que j'ai
approuvé et sur lesquelles je me suis
déjà longuement
expliqué en entendant notre rapporteur
je me suis dit que jeavais échapper
belle parce que les recommandations de
1960 heureusement je ne les avais pas lu
c'est l'année où je me suis
mariée je voudrais revenir sur deux ou
trois points du texte pour évoquer une
satisfaction trois regrets et une
inquiétude la satisfaction c'est d'avoir
pu faire prendre des dispositions
spécifiques concernant le congé parental
des parents de jumeaux et plus les
regrets
d'abord le maintien de l'adjectif réel à
collé au mot égalité comme pour le mot
laïcité je considère que tout
qualificatif app appauvrit ces deux
notionsès bien le deuxième regret le
maintien de la la médiation dans le cas
de séparation d'un couple après des
violences conjugales je ne vais pas
développer je l'ai déjà fait longuement
auparavant et le troisème regret
l'incapacité à imposer dans la haute
fonction publique ce que les entreprises
doivent bon gré malgré mettre en œuvre
pour assurer l'égalité dans leurs
instances dirigeantes et enfin une
inquiétude la difficulté qu'uront les
parents à organiser la prestation
partagée d'éducation de l'enfant mais ce
texte est globalement une grande avancée
pour l'égalité femm homme dans le champ
professionnel la protection des femmes
seules la protection des femmes victimes
de violence en particulier dans leur
couple et enfin de la parité
mon groupe sera donc majoritairement
favorable aux conclusions de la
commission mixte paritaire mais je
voudrais profiter des quelques minutes
que m'accorde cette tribune pour évoquer
devant vous madame la ministre mes chers
collègues quelques réflexions de fin de
mandat et je commencerai par l'égalité
femme homme ce n'est pas seulement 10
ans de mandat sénatorial mais toute une
vie qui m'auront amené à constater que
ce combat car s'en est un n'est jamais
fini jamais gagné il demande un travail
constant une grande vigilance de la part
des femmes dont les plus jeune mais
aussi des hommes encore trop rares qui
sont absolument convaincus que le
respect de l'égalité femme homme est une
chance pour notre démocratie et notre
société
ensuite je voudrais parler de notre
travail de sénateurs et j'exposerai deux
regrets le premier nous sommes des élus
expérimenté ayant une bonne connaissance
du terrain et beaucoup de bon sens mais
nous ne sommes ni entendus ni écoué les
conseillers des ministres jeunes et
brillants mais totalement déconnectés de
la réalité finissent toujours par avoir
raison j'excepte ceux de ce ministère
qui sont très à l'écoute mais
globalement j'ai
raison le deuxème
regret en 10 ans de mandat je me suis
rendu compte qu'on avait toujours tort
d'avoir raison trop tôt que les
suggestions faites à un moment donné et
rejeté vont revenir 2 5 10 ans plus tard
que de temps perdu et quelle gâie enfin
et c'est un vœux certainement pieux mais
il faut toujours espérer j'aimerais que
soit enfin prise en compte par les
gouvernements successifs les excellents
rapports généralement présentés par deux
sénateurs de sens ilités Politi
différentes sans doute les textes de loi
qui en découleraient pourrai recueillir
pour la meilleure efficacité auprès de
nos concitoyens une large majorité dans
cette période de crise il serait utile
d'avoir ainsi un grand nombre de textes
de consensus national qu'une grande
majorité de nos concitoyens réclam
j'espère que vous pourrez madame la
ministre mes chers collègues dans
l'avenir contribuer à ce que cette union
nationale se met en place avant d'y être
contraint contraint par une crise encore
plus grande je vous remercie de votre
attention et je vous dis au
revoir merci madame la
Présidente dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
madame Cécile cuckerman pour le groupe
CRC pas
bien Madame la la présidente madame la
ministre mes mes chers collègues le
texte élaboré par la commission mixte
paritaire pour l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes égalité réelle
tente de répondre à des problèmes
sociétaux indéiables comme nous avons pu
déjà l'évoquer lors des précédents
débats ici ce projet de loi et la preuve
s'il en était besoin que les reculs les
retards et les écarts sont encore
important en matière d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes dans notre pays
nous devons dans ce contexte rester plus
que jamais vigilant car nous avons pu le
constater encore aujourd'hui que
certains acquis pouvaient êre rapidement
être remis en cause comme le droit à
disposer de son corps ou l'accès à l'IVG
nous y étions longuement revenus
notamment en première lecture à
l'automne dernier notre pays a pris du
retard cela a été dit et les chiffres
le montre en matière d'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes il devient donc
urgent et indispensable de prendre
certaines mesures pour rendre cette
égalité effective et sortir du constat
quasi
annuel d'ailleurs quasi rutuel à chaque
8 mars qui ramène d'année en année
toujours les mêmes chiffres avec
finalement très peu d'évolution c'est
une question fondamentale du présent et
du devenir pour notre société
nous savons que tout droit nouveau à
quiis par et pour les femmes contribue à
un recul des dominations à un pas vers
une avancée de civilisation ceci est
d'autant plus vrai lorsqu'une pression
idéologique conservatrice se fait de
plus en plus forte il importe donc de
réaffirmer que toute avancée
progressiste de notre société passe par
une avancée de l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes c'est pourquoi nous
ne pouvons que nous réjouir de pouvoir
disposer d'une nouvelle loi qui annonce
un certain nombre de principes et prend
en compte un certain nombre de réalités
pour permettre réellement cette égalité
nous devons rester mobiliser pour qu'à
l'école par exemple cette éducation à
l'égalité puisse se poursuivre et
avancer et je l'espère madame la
ministre et je n'en doute pas que vous
resterez vigilante quant au projets et
aux ambitions annoncées aujourd'hui de
remplacer la BCD de l'égalité par une
volonté de généraliser à l'ensemble des
enseignants donc à l'ensemble des écoles
donc à l'ensemble des élèves filles et
garç son cette sensibilisation à
l'égalité dès le plus jeune âge pour
leur permettre de se construire dans la
société de demain toutefois même si ce
projet de loi je l'ai dit est un est un
bon début mes collègues du groupe CRC
moi-même pensons qu'il est indispensable
d'aller plus loin encore dans
l'affirmation d'engagement de mesures
parfois aussi dans la mise en place de
sanction pour que cette égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes soit respectée
cette loi tâche à rendre effective
l'égalité dans plusieurs domaines je ne
les énumérerai pas ils l'ont déjà été
précédemment par vous-même madame la
ministre permettez-moi d'insister sur le
monde du travail et de ce que plus
largement l'on appelle l'égalité
professionnelle les chiffres sont assez
révélateurs 50 % des femmes se
concentrent sur 12 familles
professionnelles quand 50 % des hommes
se concentrent sur 20 familles
professionnelles cette faible mixité ne
contribue pas à favoriser l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et trop
souvent encore nous entendons de
nombreux stéréotypes sur certains un
certain nombre de métiers de plus dans
ces inégalités professionnelles les
femmes représentent 82 % des
travailleurs des travailleuses à temps
partiel tout temps de travail confondu
nous constatons un écart de salaire dans
le privé de 24 % entre le salaires des
femmes et le salaire des hommes nous le
savons cette situation est une donnée
clé pour comprendre y compris dans
l'ensemble de la société les les
inégalités que cela génère y compris
dans ces périodes parfois plus
difficiles de crise économique qui font
que
Infiné dans la réalité pratico-pratique
de la vie d'un couple c'est aussi la
femme qui sacrifie sa carrière
professionnelle déjà mal mal commencé ou
qui parfois fait aussi le choix de se
retirer de la vie professionnelle parce
que Ben dans la vie du coup couple et au
niveau des salaires le sacrifice entre
guillemets est moins important dans
l'immédiat quand c'est la femme qui le
fait que quand c'est l'homme nous avions
donc à travers ce texte la possibilité
sur cette question de prendre des
décisions pour que la force de la loi
prévale sur le laisser faire et sur
finalement les conséquences du du
libéralisme qui renvoie chacune et
chacun à ses propres choix alors que
finalement les propres choix de chacune
et chacun ont un impact réel sur
l'ensemble de la société il est de notre
devoir de responsable politique de dire
par la loi que la règle n'est pas de
proposer des emplois à temps partiel aux
femmes les obligeant de fait à n'avoir
que des sal des salaires partiels avec
de fait également des vies partiel et
plus tard de faites également des
retraites partielles d'ailleurs l'écart
constaté sur les retraites entre une
femme et un homme est énorme 932 € pour
les femmes contre 1603 € en moyenne pour
les hommes temps partiel et précarité
voilà le lot de nombreuses femmes dans
le travail puis par la suite dans leur
retraite or nous savons et nous en
sommes je crois toutes et tous
convaincus ici que l'indépendance des
femmes passe par une autonomie
financière et que cette autonomie
financière se retrouve dans l'activité
professionnelle en grande partie sans
réell sanction et en tout cas ce ce qui
assure l'égalité après les les origines
et les héritages de chacun ne
garantissant pas l'égalité sans réelles
sanction ce cercle vicieux S entretient
voire même se développe d'ailleurs je
déplore que nous n'ayons pas été plus
loin dans ce domaine notamment
concernant la situation de nombrees
femmes artistes et professionnelles du
spectacle nous avions en première
lecture ici même au Sénat avancé dans ce
sens il nous faut également agir à la
source malheureusement dans une société
très patriarcale souvent c'est encore la
femme qui sacrifie je le disais et
parfois pour des raisons dans
l'immédiaté pratiopratique sa carrière
professionnelle pour s'occuper des
enfants pour exemple le taux d'AC iité
des femmes avec deux enfants en basâge
chute à 70 66 % contre 97 % pour les
femmes enfin Madame la ministre
permettez-moi de regretter une dernière
fois ici que sur ces questions ce texte
se retrouve comme je l'ai rappelé
prisonnier du carcan de Laan de la
réforme des retraites et d'une politique
d'austérité qui frappe nous le savons
plus encore les personnes vulnérables
dont de nombreuses femmes victimes du
chômage du plafond de verre les quelques
dérogations envisagées asses lo
intérieurs qui construisent le système
en vigueur n suffiront certainement pas
mais nous pensons cependant madame
ministre que ce texte est une première
étape qui entend à bouleverser la
réalité et les mentalités et nous
voterons donc ce texte issu de la CMP
merci madame la
sénatrice dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à madame
Anne-Marie Escoffier pour le groupe
RDSE
reprend madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le président de la
commission des lois madame le rapporteur
chers collègues au cours et je regrette
qu'on puisse pas mettre collègue au
féminin et au masculin mais vous êes un
mot commun c'est très bien justement ça
permet de bien montrer l'harmonie entre
nous tous au cours des dernières
décennies la place et les droits des
femmes dans la société française ont
connu d'indéiables progrès
pour autant nous le savons bien les
inégalités persistent et l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes demeure un
horizon difficile à atteindre le projet
de loi que vous avez élaboré madame la
ministre est ambitieux il aborde la
question dans toutes ces dimensions et
ça je crois que c'est vraiment un point
fort et important égalité
professionnelle lutte contre la
précarité protection contre les violence
image des femmes dans les médias parité
en politique et dans les responsabilités
sociales et prof n la tâche était
difficile car l'égalité ne se proclame
pas c'est un patient travail de fond qui
doit permettre de sortir des lieux
communs aussi madame la ministre modifie
en profondeur les comportements
notamment en matière d'égalité
professionnel est un objectif louable et
nous y souscrivons pleinement je l'ai
dit votre texte est ambitieux comporte
des avancées importantes notamment en
matière de lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes avancé que nous
approuvons je me réjouis d'ailleurs que
les débats en Première et en 2uxème
lecture aent enrichi ce
volet je pense à la généralisation du
dispositif de téléprotection femmes en
très grand danger à l'immunité pénale
pour les centrre d'hébergement qui
accueill les victimes de violence à
l'obligation de formation sur les
violences faites aux femmes pour les
différentes professions qui
interviennent dans la lutte contre les
violences mais je pense également et je
voudrais saluer le travail de Françoise
bord ma collègue qui a été constamment
sur ce dossier qui l'a accompagné qui
l'a suivi et qui aurait voulu être là
aujourd'hui au banc madame la ministre
mais qui ne l'a pas pu et qui m'a chargé
de porter ses messages donc je pense à
l'amendement de Madame la bord qui
modifiait la procédure disciplinaire
dans l'enseignement supérieur et la
recherche il était nécessaire de porter
une attention particulière à la lutte
contre le harcèlement et les violences
sexuelles dans le milieu universitaire
face auquel les étudiante se trouent
aujourd'hui nous le savons bien en
situation de vulnérabilité il fallait
mettre un terme à l'impunité dont
jouissent les auteurs de ces actes les
modifications apportées tant par
l'Assemblée nationale que par le Sénat
sont pleinement
satisfaites je pense aussi évidemment à
l'obligation pour le juge de se
prononcer sur le retrait partiel ou
total de l'autorité parentale à un
parent coupable de violence
intrafamiliale faisant ainsi écho à une
proposition défendue encore une fois par
Françoise Laborde en première lecture le
maintien de l'autorité parentale lorsque
de tels actes de violence sont commis
est incompréhensibible et nous
connaissons bien les effets dévastateurs
sur les enfants tant sur leur
personnalité que sur leur développement
notre groupe madame la ministre se
félicite que vous ayez été sensible aux
préoccupations que nous avons soulevé en
première lecture s'agissant de la
délivrance de l'ordonnance de protection
à une femme menacée de mariage forcé
vous vous êes vous êtes engagé à
travailler avec le ministère chargé des
Français de l'étranger à une meilleure
information des Françaises et des
Français concerné à un meilleur
accompagnement grâce à l'action de nos
consulats et je vous en remercie je
tiens enfin à saluer la position de
notre rapporteur qui sur le volet parité
a défendu une démarche pragmatique quand
les réalités sociologique ne permettent
pas d'exiger une représentation
strictement paritaire comme vous savez
nous pensons que la parité est un
objectif certes tout à fait louable mais
qu'il serait excessif de vouloir
l'imposer partout et à tout prix la
parité ne peut pas s'imposer au
détriment du mérite et là je pourrais
faire de nombreux commentaires
s'agissant sur la parité dans le monde
de la justice dans le monde de
l'éducation nationale ou j'aimerais bien
peut-être à titre personnel qu'un jour
on imposa un quotat d'homme et pas de
femme le texte de la CMP n'a adopté que
quatre articles dans la rédaction du
Sénat 4/ 30 c'est bien peu il est
dommage que les députés ne se soient pas
plus rangés à l'avis de notre rapporteur
s'agissant notamment du délit de
diffusion d'images de violence de la
même façon je trouve qu'il n'était pas
utile d'ajoutter l'adjectif réel dans
l'intitulé du projet de loi et je
partage pleinement votre position
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois l'adjectif vous l'avez dit et
je le reprends à mon compte n'apporte
rien d'un point de vue juridique et
affaiblit le sens du texte nous
regrettons enfin qu'au cours des débats
la disposition portée par le le RDSE
favorisant la résidence alternée est
finalement été rejeté il s'agit pourtant
d'un sujet particulièrement douloureux
qui aurait mérité d'être abordé dans le
cadre de cette loi car si la justice ne
doit pas pouvoir imposer la résidence
alternée des enfants en cas de divorce
rien ne doit pouvoir l'empêcher lorsque
l'un des parents le demande il y a aussi
dans ce domaine beaucoup de progrès à
faire pour combattre les préjugés et
tendre vers une égalité entre les hommes
et les femmes madame la ministre en
dépit de ces quelques dernières
observations vous aurez compris que mon
groupe RDSE dans sa grande majorité
adoptera ce projet j'ai lois mais il me
faudrait pour moi-même beaucoup de temps
pour ajouter en mon nom propre celui
l'expérience d'une femme qui a toujours
combattu les excès où qu'il soit à
quelque niveau qu'elle soit et qui
viennent rompre l'équilibre harmonieux
auquel nous devrions tendre l'homme et
la femme dans leur différence mais dans
leur complémentarité avec leurs talents
et leurs compétences seul critère qui me
paraî devoir être privilégié au
quotidien merci madame la
ministre dans la suite de la discussion
générale la parole est à Madame Michel
Meier pour le groupe
socialiste madame la Présidente Monsieur
président de la commission des lois
madame la
ministre madame
la rapporteur mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues nous y voilà nous examinons
donc aujourd'hui les conclusions de la
CMP sur le projet de loi pour l'égalité
réelle entre les femmes et les hommes
après des mois de travaux sur ce texte
la rapporteur pour avis que j'ai été est
très fière et très heureuse que ce texte
de loi soit en voie d'être voté
définitivement fire car je crois que
notre Assemblée a bien travaillé et
qu'elle a permis des avancées sensi sur
plusieurs points heureuse car ce premier
texte cadre a pour but de rendre réel
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
réelle dans les textes dans les têtes et
dans les faites et je me réjouis pour ma
part que le terme égalité réelle a été
repris par la CMP dans l'intitulé de ce
projet de loi nous savons que le chemin
vers l'égalité si cher à notre
République est toujours à emprunter et
je dirais particulièrement en matière
d'égalité de genre le pas que nous
sommes en train de franchir aujourd'hui
est important afin que les filles et les
femmes de notre pays puissent pleinement
choisir leur vie et vivre en égalité
avec les hommes et ceci dès le plus
jeune âge et tout au long de la vie que
ce soit dans la sphère professionnelle
familiale politique ou associatif il
s'agit en fait de permettre aux femmes
de prendre leur place pleine et entière
dans le fonctionnement économique social
et citoyens de notre pays et la société
toute entière a à y
gagner bien sûr il reste encore du
chemin à faire et il n'y a pas de
fatalité il nous faut du courage et de
la volonté pour faire changer les choses
car c'est une construction humaine qui
induit qui impose des comportements
sexuels aux hommes comme aux femmes à
partir d'une différence biologique
relative à la reproduction de notre
espèce humaine c'est'est installé un
rapport de domination des hommes sur les
femmes dans toute la société et nous
pouvons donc changer ce rapport et
précisément comme il s'agit d'une
construction humaine nous devons nous
attaquer sans relâche aux résistances
aux préjugés aux habitudes aux réflexes
il est de notre devoir de parlementaire
d'agir et de changer la loi pour que les
comportements évoluent et c'est bien le
sens de ce texte et du travail que nous
avons réalisé ensemble pour le pousser
plus loin encore et mobiliser
conjointement tous les leviers pour
faire appliquer les textes modifier les
comportements et atteindre enfin
l'égalité partout pour toutes et tous
l'analyse des mécanismes
discriminatoires nous a permis d'engager
j'ai une démarche originale à plus d'un
titre et ce texte cherche à rendre plus
effectif et plus appliquer les mesures
déjà existants en droit français et ce
texte permet également l'innovation et
l'expérimentation avant de généraliser
les mesures qu'il contient l'article 1er
que nous avons examiné dans le cadre de
la
CMP résume bien l'objectif qui a Guité
le gouvern et les parlementairire dans
la recherche d'un cadre cohérent pour la
politique conduite en faveur de
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
une politique qui vise à lutter contre
la précarité des femmes à garantir
l'égalité professionnelle et salarial ou
encore à favoriser une meilleure
articulation des temps de vie et un
partage équilibré des responsabilité
parentale entre les pères et mères une
politique aussi qui vise à renforcer la
lutte contre le système prostitutionnel
et à ce propos quelques mots puisque
vous connaissez mes convictions à la
matière et j'ai pu les exprimer en tant
que rapporteur de la commission spéciale
lors de nos récents travaux au Sénat
j'estime comme c'est inscrit dans la
formulation retenue en CMP que l'achat
d'un acte sexuel est dans tous les cas
une violence une violence contre
laquelle il faut lutter en s'attaquant
bien sûr au réseau mafieux de traite des
êtres humains mais également en
responsabilisant les clients qui ne sont
pas pour rien dans l'existence de ce
système
prostitutionnel nous aurons l'occasion
madame la ministre de débattre de ces
points en séance publique je le souhaite
à la rentrée prochaine abordons
maintenant le contenu du projet de loi
tel que nous est présenté aujourd'hui
tout d'abord les dispositions en faveur
d'un partage plus équitable des
responsabilités parentales
la mesure la plus emblématique d'entre
elle est l'installation l'instauration
d'une période de partage entre les deux
parents des droits au complément de
libre choix
d'activité cela a été dit 96 % des
bénéficiaires actuels sont des femmes et
l'article 2 a pour but de rendre cette
mesure plus égalitaire en incitant les
pirres à réduire ou à interrompre leur
activité professionnelle pour s'occuper
de leur enfant et ainsi prendre toute
leur place dans la vie de famille mais
il s'agit aussi d'améliorer le retour à
l'emploi des maères qui le souhaitent et
ainsi contribuer à l'égalité salariale
et professionnelle entre les femmes et
les hommes l'égalité professionnelle est
justement le deuxième point que je
souhaite aborder certes les écarts de
salaires ont eu tendance à se réduire un
peu ces dernières années mais en 2014
une femme doit toujours travailler 77
jours de plus qu'un homme pour toucher
le même salaire à poste équivalent le
chantier n'est donc pas terminé madame
la ministre pour parvenir à l'égalité
sur le terrain professionnel le projet
de loi développe différentes mesures
bien ciblées parmi lesquelles rendre la
commande publique exemplaire vous en
avez parlé ne plus laisser les
collaboratrices libérales sans
protection faciliter l'articulation des
tempend de vie ou encore inscrire en
droit les conclusions de la négociation
nationale interpr professionnel sur la
qualité de vie au travail et l'égalité
professionnelle à l'issue de la CMP nous
avons également attribuer un nouveau
droit au père à l'article 2 bb en
autorisant trois absences
professionnelles pour se rendre avec
leur compagnes aux examens prénataux
c'est à mes yeux une mesure qui
contribue au partage plus équilibré des
responsabilité parentale et ce dès les
premiers mois de grossesse permettre
ainsi aux pères de prendre leur place
avant l'arrivée de l'enfant est une
bonne chose aussi
pour la parentalité et soutien la
parentalité ce projet de loi je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure vise également à lutter
contre la précarité précarité qui touche
en premier lieu les femmes et le constat
est frappant une femme sur deux élevant
seul ses enfants déclare ne pas parvenir
à boucler son budget sans être à
découvert le non paiement ou le paiement
aléatoire des pensions alimentaires en
cas de séparation est loin d'être une
exception on le retrouve dans 40 % des
cas les peines applicables sont lourdes
en théorie mais très rarement appliqué
rarement appliqué or ce sont de nombreux
enfants qui dans les fait vivent les
situations de grande précarité voire de
pauvreté pour ne pas laisser ses
familles sans solution l'article 6
prévoit la mise en œuvre via lescaf
d'une garantie publique contre les
impayés de alimentaire et cette mesure
s'accompagne à l'article 6 seè d'une
expérimentation du tiers payant pour le
versement de complément de libre choix
du mode de garde pour les familles
modestes cela limitera d'autant les
avances d'argent pour les familles ayant
des budgets très serrés et nous avons
porté à 18 mois la durée de cette
expérimentation je l'ai dit cette loi
est transversale et à vocation à à
s'attaquer aux inégalités partout où
elle se trouve c'est-à-dire
partout et ce texte vise aussi à
renforcer la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes comme vous madame la
ministre je constate ce continuum des
inégalités et des violences dans notre
société qui maintient les femmes dans un
état de dépendance et
d'infériorité lutter contre les
violences envers les femmes ce n'est pas
simple c'est même le point de résistance
le plus profond mais agir pour l'égalité
n'aurait pas de sens si ce n'était pas
pour éliminer les violences changer les
regards et les mentalités et condamner
les auteurs et protéger les victimes
l'ampleur des violences notamment des
violences sexuelles subies par les
enfants les filles ou les femmes sont
telles que nous ne pouvons pas les
ignorer et encore moins baisser les bras
ce sont des violences exercées
majoritairement dans l'espace privé par
des garçons des hommes proches de leurs
victimes et sans témoins la situation
d'emprise et de peur dans laquelle les
femmes sont maintenues les empêche
souvent d'en parler et de se faire et
aider d'être accompagné or quand elles
ne sont pas traitées nous savons les
conséquences psychologiques désastreus
qui subissent et qui perdurent toute la
vie nous ne pouvons plus accepter qu'une
enfant une jeune fille une adolescente
une femme soit exposée à la violence du
seul fait qu'elle soit de sexe féminin
c'est tout simplement intolérable je
citerai quelquesunes des mesures
contenues dans ce projet de loi le
renforcement de l'ordonnance de
protection en en réduisant les délais de
délivrance ou en prolongeant sa durée
d'effectivité mieux définir les
violences psychologiques pour mieux les
traiter ne plus proposer la médiation
pénale comme réponse à la violence
conjugale faire de l'éviction du
domicile le principe général et non son
maintien l'exception protéger les femmes
en très grand danger en les dotant d'un
téléphone d'appel d'urgence assurer la
gratuité des titres de séjour pour les
femmes étrangères victime de violence
mieux responsabiliser les auteurs de
violence poursivre les plans de
formation des professionnels au-delà ces
différents points il me semble important
de veiller à l'application de la loi et
aux réponses apportées aux victimes par
le système judiciaire victimes encore
trop peu nombreuses à dénoncer les
auteurs de violence trop peu nombreuses
à porter plainte et trop peu nombreux et
trop peu d'acteurs d'auteurs pardon
sanctionnés je terminerai mon propos par
la parité le texte traduit en effet
l'engagement du président de la
République de renforcer considérablement
les sanctions financières pour les
partis politiques qui ne respectent pas
leurs obligations à la matière cette
mesure est hautement symbolique car le
monde politique se doit d'être
exemplaire en matière
d'égalité en effet comment encourager
les entreprises les structures sportives
ou médiatique à agir pour l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes si les
instances politiques n'avancent pas sur
ces questions de parit
mais au-delà de la parité au sein des
institutions locales ou nationales qui
avance scrutin après scrutin du fait des
récent réformes il faudra nous attaquer
lors de prochains rendez-vous
parlementaires à la parité au sein des
exécutifs et au partage de l'ensemble
des responsabilités le projet de loi est
en pass d'être voté il marque pour nous
la fin d'une étape et comme je suis d'un
naturel optimiste j'ai envie de croire
avec vous chers collègues que ce texte
qui a réuni un fort consensus politique
et qui nous permet de franchir un pas
considérable nous engage encore plus et
que le travail ne pourra que continuer
au-delà de la session parlementaire qui
s'achève nous pourrons reprendre ce
chantier avec enthousiasme et
détermination à l'occasion d'un nouveau
cycle pour notre assemblée qui débutera
après les élections sénatoriales et
l'application de son nouveau mode de
scrutin ce sera l'occasion mes chers
collègues d'en mesurer les effets et
d'être enfin je l'espère un peu plus que
23 % de sénatrices dans cet hémicycle je
vous
remercie merci madame la
sénatrice la discussion générale est
close je rappelle qu'en application de
l'article 42 aléa 12 du règlement aucun
amendement n'est recevable sauf accord
du gouvernement le Sénat étant appelé à
se prononcer avant l'Assemblée nationale
il statue sur les éventuels amendements
puis par un seul vote sur l'ensemble du
texte je ne suis saisie d'aucun
amendement conformément à l'article 42
alinéa 12 du règlement je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble du projet de loi dans la
rédaction résultant du texte proposé par
la Commission Mixte Paritaire il y
a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote madame
Goulet oui madame le Président Madame le
ministre mes chers collègues je pense
que tout à peu près était été dit sur ce
sujet je n'avais pas l'intention de
prendre la parole mais en écoutant
certains orateurs et en fonction de de
mon parcours personnel j'avais quand
même envie de de vous dire plusieurs
choses la première c'est que
effectivement on préfère tout je suppose
le combat au au quota euh mais que
néanmoins sans sans quota il est
difficile parfois de mener des combats
car les obstacles sont nombreux pour les
femmes de façon à arver aux
responsabilités ce n'est pas une chose
très simple parce que vous avez un 110 m
ha d'hommes élus depuis longtemps et il
faut passer à travers les fourches
codines des partis politiques ou pas et
qu'effectivement je pense que le mode de
scrutin été adopté va permettre de voir
plus de femmes dans cet hémicycle mais
surtout euh si beaucoup d'entre nous
n'ont pas eu de de soucis beaucoup
d'autres en nont et c'est plutôt par
solidarité que que jeux voterai ce texte
et je voulais simplement rappeler à
l'assemblée que c'est le 100e jour
aujourd'hui que des jeunes filles
nigérianes ont été kidnappé par Boko
Haram et que dans certains pays de de ce
monde le fait d'être une femme est n
n'est pas n'est pas très simple à
assurer et que donc nous qui sommes ici
dans des conditions extrêmement facile
d'exercice de nos droits nous devons
penser aussi à celles qui n'en ont pas
dans une vie antérie illeur mon ex
compagnon me doit 18 ans de pension
alimentaire donc je vois aussi les
difficultés sur ce sujet et le texte va
sûrement là aussi améliorer un certain
nombre de choses donc pour pour toutes
ces raisons je voterai le texte et la la
dernière raison est aussi un hommage au
travail de de muguet Dini qui a décidé
de de de ne pas solliciter un nouveau
mandat qu'elle aurait sûrement obtenu
auut la main euh elle elle est une voix
posé délicate et énergique dans la
défense de nombreux droits on l'a encore
vu il y a quelques semaines sur les
violences faites aux femmes et et je
pense que sa voix nous manquera dans cet
hémicycle merci merci madame la
sénatrice je ne vois pas d'autres
demande d'explication de vote monsieur
le président de la commission des lois
vous avez la parole ou merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre mes chers
collègues je voulais simplement dire que
je voterai ce texte avec beaucoup de
conviction parce que je pense en effet
que ce texte il contient en
lui-même tellement de combats de lutte
de
mouvement de
difficultés connu vécu porté par les
femmes de ce pays tout
particulièrement pour cette égalité
je le voterai
nonobstant le fait qu'un
adjectif est subsister malgré nos
efforts au sein de la commission mixte
paritaire je voulais donner là-dessus
quelques
explication on croit toujours qu'en
ajoutant des adjectifs ou parfois des
adverbes on renforce le propos mais tel
n'est pas le
cas voez-vous Paul
etuard il a écrit un magnifique poème
que tout le monde connaît j'écris ton
nom
liberté il n'a pas fait une
Hae à la liberté
réelle
véritable
authentique il y a des mots qui ont une
telle
force qu'il faut qu'il s'impose dans
leur
plénitude ainsi à avons-nous défendu la
laïcité alors que certains voulaient que
l'on ajouta cet adjectif
positif la la laïcité positive ce qui
présupposait
inévitablement qu'il pourrait y avoir
une
laïcité négative comme s'il y avait
madame la ministre une égalité
irréelle donc je plaide bien
sûr mais ce pourquoi vous vous battez
cher Michel benier avec beaucoup de
talent c'est tout simplement
l'égalité la République n'a jamais
souhaité que l'on changea notre devise
pour parler de l'égalité
véritable de la liberté authentique et
de la fraternité réelle les mots ont un
sens et nous en tant que législateur
nous nous devons continuer cette œuvre
qui ne qui consiste à n'être pas
forcément bavard mais comme le disait le
grand poète Stéphane malarmé à donner un
sens plus pur au mots de la tribu
donnons le sens le plus fort possible à
ces mots comme le mot égalité et qu'il
me soit permis puisque j'ai la parole
madame la Présidente et je vous en
remercie de saluer euh quelques
personnes madame Goulet a parlé de
Madame Dini qui a mené ce combat je
voulais saluer particulièrement
euh madame prince elle me le permettra
puisqu'elle a choisi de ne pas
poursuivre son mandat qui a mené avec
beaucoup de force ces combats pour les
convictions qu'elle porte en elle et
vous me permettrez aussi en ce jour de
saluer l'action de notre rapporteur j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure de notre rapporteur
pour avis mais qui restera au Sénat mais
je veux parler de Virginie Clais et la
remerciit très sincèrement parce que
comme j'ai eu l'occasion de lui dire ce
matin Virginie cl est une femme de
conviction et qui a constamment défendu
ici avec beaucoup de ferveur ses
convictions et vous venez encore une
fois Virginie CLIS d'en apporter la
preuve par votre intervention donc
soyez-en très sincèrement remercier
merci monsieur le
Président je n'ai pas d'autre demande
d'explication de vote donc je pardon
vous avez compris tout le monde aura
compris que rien n'ut était possible
sans madame la ministre Najat Vallot
belgassem que je remercie également
parce que madame la ministre je puis
témoigner nous pouvons témoigner que
vous avez fait preuve d'une grand grande
ténacité pour que ce texte soit
premièrement élaboré deuxièmement adopté
au Conseil des ministres et
troisièmement qu'il trouve sa place dans
les agendas parlementaires donc nous
vous devons
également grand remerciement et vous
voyez que je me permets d'ajouter en
l'espèce un petit
adjectif merci monsieur le Président
suor je suis saisie d'un d'une demande
de scrutin public par le groupe
socialiste sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi il va donc être procéder au scrutin
public dans les conditions fixées par
l'article 56 du
règlement donner le résultat du scrutin
numéro 241 sur l'ensemble du projet de
loi pour l'égalité réelle entre les
femmes et les hommes dans la rédaction
du texte proposé par la Commission Mixte
Paritaire nombre de votants
344 nombre de suffrages exprimés
199 pour l'adoption
199 le Sénat a adopté ce projet de
loi et je donne la parole à Madame la
Ministre merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente bien mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je ne serai pas plus
longue je vous dirai simplement que dans
la vie d'un ministre d'une ministre il y
a quelques rares moments d'émotion pure
et que l'adoption d'un texte de loi
comme celui-ci en est évidemment un je
veux vous remercier pour la qualité du
travail effectué ici c'est 24 he j'ai
calculé 24 heures de débat tout compris
c'est des amendements nombreux qui ont
été présentés mais 45 % de vos
amendements ont été retenus et sont
venus enrichir ce texte c'est ce qui
fait aussi sa qualité aujourd'hui donc
merci et très longue vie à cette loi
merci pardonnez-moi madame la Présidente
comme monsieur le président de la
commission des lois je me permets de
reprendre la parole pour vous saluer
vous madame la Présidente je crois que
c'est la dernière fois que vous siégerez
en tout cas comme présidente dans cette
assemblée et je veux vous remercier pour
la façon dont vous l'avez fait avec
beaucoup de sérénité en nous rappelant à
l'ordre aussi souvent que possible mais
c'était nécessaire sur ces sujets sur
lesquels nous nous enflamons souvent
merci
encore